fueron tres la paz la estabilidad
política y las oportunidades para
Irlanda del Norte el presidente insistió
nuevamente en el compromiso y restricto
de todo el gobierno y el pueblo en
general de Estados Unidos con la paz en
Irlanda del Norte dijo que perseverar en
la paz en esta región es una prioridad
para Estados Unidos se debe trabajar a
diario para preservarla no se puede
volver a la violencia de hace 25 años y
Espera que pronto se conforme Un
gobierno regional que como recordábamos
hace más de un año no hay un ejecutivo
conformado esto porque el partido
unionista está boicoteando la
posibilidad de armar un gobierno de
coalición por los desafíos que trajo el
brexit justamente dijo que el brexit
trajo por supuesto grandes desafíos y
debe buscarse lo mejor para Irlanda del
Norte y el acuerdo Wilson haciéndole un
guiño al gobierno británico trae y
protege la paz por ello felicitó a
Richie sunak y a la Unión Europea por
haber hecho estas enmiendas al acuerdo
post brexit para esta región en
específico lo que se llamaba el
protocolo de Irlanda del Norte
Luisa Cuál es la importancia entonces de
que Estados Unidos apoye la paz en
Irlanda del Norte
la sola visita del presidente de Estados
Unidos a Irlanda del Norte esta región
tan convulsa aquí en el Reino Unido es
un apoyo bien importante un espaldarazo
porque Joe biden se ha comprometido con
la aceleraciones futuras de que Estados
Unidos estará ahí siempre garantizando
que se preserve la paz en el futuro Pero
además pone muchísima más presión en el
gobierno de Richie sunak para que el
gobierno británico se comprometa y
proteja aún más la paz que podría
considerarse vulnerable en esta región
británica sobre todo ahora que el brexit
ha traído nuevos desafíos nuevos
problemas así que es bien importante
este espaldarazo que ha dado el
presidente Joe biden y especialmente ese
compromiso con las nuevas generaciones y
en orden en Irlanda del Norte se espera
entonces que ese nuevo compromiso ese
reiterar esa decisión futura de
acompañar a Irlanda del Norte llegue con
nuevas inversiones estadounidenses el
presidente biden viajará a la República
de Irlanda a dublín donde cumplirá una
agenda política se reunirá con el Primer
Ministro con el presidente también dará
un discurso al parlamento de ese país
para luego iniciar la parte más personal
de esta gira por la isla de Irlanda y es
visitar algunas de las regiones más
importantes para sus ancestros